I think the biggest obstacle to success
is a lack of optimism I think the world
like lacks optimism I think you know
everyone's like your energy your energy
I've come to realize it's just optimism
just happy just positive that's what it
is just like whatever chemicals are my
body they just allow me to see the
bright side like and I just don't think
I've realized how few people have that
like no very few people have it as black
and white hundred zero like I just think
everything's good but like it doesn't
come naturally a lot of people I think I
think that's like you know if I was able
to say I'm lucky about some things
forget about the business results it's
lucky that that optimism comes naturally
to me like I'm just optimistic like I
just think that so much works for me
because I refuse to accept the negative
like I you know and I don't think I hate
when people say it's you know it's an
option or it's a choice I agree with you
Susan I don't think it comes natural to
everybody I think we are just starting
on the early stages of a really looking
at mental health the brain meditation
what I want to do with my attention is
allow the 2,000 of you to have tens of
thousands of you to take it I want to
hand you my optimism my happiness my my
view of the world my opportunities that
I see in the white space and I want to
give it to you for free and then I want
you to win
you